Larry P. Arnn: The Constitution and current
politics. The Constitution is 227-28 years
old this year.
Richard: Our fathers set forth on this continent
a new nation conceived in liberty.
Larry P. Arnn: This is the great constitutional
crisis that the conservative movement was
born to face.
Larry Kudlow: This is a fight worth preserving.
Not only because of its track record, it's
a fight worth preserving for the generations
ahead of us—for the unborn. That's why this
is so important. I'm a great believer that
democracies breed Free Market Capitalism.
Life, yes. Liberty, yes. Pursuit of happiness
means you are free to fail or succeed, and
in so doing you will produce great things
that nobody believed possible. I don't ever,
ever want to lose that freedom.
Heather: The lesson from the last 20 years
of immigration policy is that lawlessness
breeds more lawlessness. If someone cannot
be removed for illegal entry, then there is
no more immigration law.
Larry P. Arnn: Our government, by consent,
is justified by the fact that we can talk
to each other. We have human souls which is
a reflection of the divine soul.
Martha: When the cold war ended, the United
States government got out of the business
of representing the United States to the rest
of the world.
Larry Kudlow: If we want to be optimistic
about the great country of ours and the great
economy of ours, we, you and I, are going
to have to fight like hell to preserve it.